multi-marie hi babe
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
[Applause]
Nick Jonas and Priyanka chopra's
daughter malti makes her first public
appearance really special yep the
one-year-old made her debut at the Jonas
Brothers Walk of Fame ceremony
to my beautiful wife you are the the
calm and the crazy
The Rock in the storm and I love being
married to you it is the greatest gift
and I love being a parent with you so
multi-marie I've been
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
[Applause]
you sat up front with mom watching dad
as he receives his Hollywood star with
her uncles Kevin and Joe it's a special
thing and you know I think as as parents
it's everything has a new meaning and
has even more meaning and moments like
this especially
moment for the boy band who reunited in
2019 after first starting up in the
mid-2000s listen y'all are bringing new
meaning to the lyrics Hollywood here we
come you are so fermented in history
what does this honor mean to you
you said it I mean it's Hollywood here
we come that's a song of ours from well
back when I actually thought of that
when we walked up I was like this is
kind of trippy um it's just unbelievable
I think we're kind of in shock I'm not
sure how to really feel yet it's one of
those things as we were up on stage I
was just looking back at all the names
behind us Backstreet Boys some iconic
fans and artists from back in the day
and it's just to be
near them means it means the world that
we're neighbors the whole Jonas family
attended in support including their
parents Denise and Kevin Senior Mom Dad
we love you so much
we would literally not be here without
you and little bro Frankie and Franklin
Jonas
[Applause]
we love you we're so grateful you're
here Joe's wife Sophie Turner also
cheered from the sidelines Sophie what
up homie
you're my partner in crime you keep me
motivated and inspired every day I
strive to be as cool as you to my little
ones at home Daddy loves you to the moon
and back Joe and Sophie have kept their
children out of the spotlight just as
Nick and Priyanka have mostly done with
malty you have to make peace with the
fact that we're in a public job earlier
this month the actress opened up to
British Vogue about public criticism
when it comes to her and her daughter
she says she's developed a tough hide
but it's painful when people talk about
her baby girl quote I'm like keep her
out of it she's not going to be gossip
honey no and since becoming parents Nick
shared with E.T The New Joys of life
with malty it is certainly life-changing
she's uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of Joy all is good
[Music]